yes Baba Booey Roberts boyfriend Dennis
Rodman is here Dennis Rodman a great
basketball player I'm in that Billy I'm
dying to find out what happened
I'm Chuck Woolery ladies and gentlemen
back in June
[Music]
to either one of us
here he is the great Dennis Rodman look
at him better-looking than ever I swear
to god you're lucky huh
looking over at Robin let me find out
what happened on this date okay when you
were here the last time there was
something between you and Robin Robin
was obviously making it known that she
was attracted to you you're a very
handsome man is that true well last
night she said she want to go out again
she did like it with you regular that's
right
you're a man who knows how to have fun I
want to take upstairs and give a
goodnight kiss but her bodyguard was
that right did he kiss you goodnight on
the cheek yeah what your ass cheek
that's oh wait a second let me
understand something you have a cool
move when you asked out Robin you had
your person call up Gary oh yeah
and give a list of available times that
Robin could fly to Chicago and be with
you and he would fly her there and then
she would have to come on such-and-such
a date when you're free but she has
opening the ticket so if she falls in
love she can stay for as long as she
wants right right Yeah right that's it
Robin when she heard that she says I'm
not flying to Chicago I'm not gonna go
there he's making me go there and just
spread my legs so like a gentleman you
rebooked
another day you said I'm available on
Monday night and let's face it you have
a pretty busy dating card you're
good-looking and you guys you know you
guys want to go out again right so so so
you you pick her up in a limousine am i
correct yeah cuz you got big bucks yeah
are you saving any of your money I'm
gonna hang out with Robin I gotta have
some kind of money right fancy
restaurant last night it's Italian
restaurant you took her to an Italian
right now when you walk in with Robin
you are a power couple am I correct of
course you should see what she had I was
real short skirt and really sitting down
all the city just start to itch up
it's always been a down like this so you
went to an Italian restaurant and Dennis
brought flowers yes and you went in
there the restaurant the Italian
restaurant and was good food oh yeah
Robin and eat at all I did you sure you
had good conversation we thought penises
and how this but we've talked about OJ
and you believe that and Robin were you
turned on by Dennis cuz I know you like
him physically I'll show a picture of me
last night
what nude with two women oh yeah and we
do genitals exposed almost and what did
you think of that picture Rob well then
you went to this restaurant and then you
took a ride home after the restaurant no
we were to the Bowery bar yeah a bar and
what happens when you walk into a bar
don't doesn't the place go crazy and
left the table for a few minutes the
next thing I know dennis has a lesbian
screaming that she wants him to come
home and make love to her girlfriend and
she just she really oh yeah so say hey
if Robert doesn't put out who cares
because you can get anybody else I get
that kind of idea on this date that it
was more like a friendship date because
there was no sex and he's getting
propositioned every minute so how can
you have an intelligent conversation
because so what a night she kissed him
on the cheek and there was a hmm alright
anyway listen Dennis good luck in the
game tonight
I hope you have better luck with the
next thing you did with Robin oh she was
dying to have sex with you man and you
didn't
put it all together why didn't you just
did you read the signals one last time
yes oh just be quiet I'm not answering
any more because we have some type of
JSON you know I thought you were so
sweet last night I go out with you again
yeah well you got some kind of charm
going yeah it's all in do so and then
what lower region